foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I want to let all of you know when
we will see the second season of House
of the Dragon according to an executive
from HBO in a new interview he lets all
of us fans know when we should see the
follow-up of House of the dragon's
incredibly successful first season now
in the back half of this video I will
also go over what happened during one of
House of the dragon's most controversial
scenes during its season 1 finale in
that video House of the dragon's writer
and showrunner describes exactly what
was happening during one of renera and
Damon's final scenes in the season make
sure you stick around at the end of this
video so you can see what he had to say
alright now first let's see when we will
get to watch the second season of House
of the Dragon like I said during a new
interview Casey bloy sat down with
vulture to discuss HBO's Game of Thrones
successor show after discussing what
happened at the end of Game of Thrones
as well as how much success House of the
Dragon has had during its first season
they finally discuss when we should see
what will happen next it says as for
what's next for the reinvigorated Game
of Thrones Universe bloy says fans of
House of the Dragon will almost surely
have to wait a while for the second
season unfortunately he says we most
likely will not see it next year which
as you all know is only a few months
away he says he believes we will see it
during the following year in 2024. now I
know that might sound horrible because
let's be honest having to wait it all
does suck however this is no different
for us Die Hard Game of Thrones fans who
also had to wait this long for the final
season of The Show for all of you who
have been following me for a while know
this is nothing new we have been here
before and as I've said in other videos
I will still be here helping you get
through this long night as we wait for
the second season I am about to begin
making videos this week about everything
we should see in the new season also you
have to remember filming will begin very
soon and once that happens we will start
to see photos of the actors on set and
that will begin to let us know exactly
what's happening in some other scenes as
always I will be here making videos
every step of the way during the off
season you will be updated on everything
that's happening with House of the
dragon's second season as well as any of
the other Game of Thrones shows they
have in development also not to mention
George R Martin did just recently
announce he's now 75 done with the wins
of winter so maybe just maybe we will
see his next novel before House of the
Dragon releases in about 18 months now I
know some of you might also be wondering
why in the hell do we have to wait for
so long for the next season well you
have to remember this next season of
House of the Dragon will have a lot more
episodes than Game of Thrones season 7
and Game of Thrones season 8. it should
have upwards of three extra hours of
footage to release not only that but
House of the dragon's second season will
also feature a number of different
battles involving dragons fighting each
other in the sky something we never
really saw in Game of Thrones now we did
see Dany and Jon Fight the Night King
while he was on his resurrected Dragon
but that was barely a fight what we're
about to see and how so the dragon will
knock your socks off unfortunately if we
want to see one of the greatest stories
get brought to life on the screen then
we will have to wait for them to make it
look as amazing as they did in the first
season and even with that being said I'm
hoping the second season will look even
better now that they already know House
of the Dragon is a massive success with
an enormous fan base behind it ready for
more I'm sure HBO will open up the bank
for this follow-up season everything
should look bigger and better I without
a doubt know it will be worth the wait
remember when everyone was against the
idea of HBO making another Game of
Thrones show after the failure of season
8 I was the one here making videos
saying it would be a success when
everyone was against Matt Smith saying
he wasn't right for Damon Targaryen I
was the one here making videos saying he
would be amazing so all I'm asking for
is to have some faith that everything
will be worth it in the end the days and
weeks and months will fly by like they
always do and before we know it we will
be right back here discussing how great
the new season is I'm hoping all of you
will stand beside me as we enter the new
long night in order for me and my videos
to survive I will need your help as we
wait for House of the dragon and
hopefully the Jon Snow Show and The
Winds of Winter as always I want to
thank all of you for showing some love
and watching my new video also don't
forget I have another video I will be
showing you right now have a great day
everyone I will see you again very soon
bye
what
the coming war against the darkness in
the north a conqueror's dream
Sarah shared it with me when he named
Tamia
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I will be discussing one of Damon
and Rainier's scenes during the season
one finale of House of the Dragon in
House of the dragon's final episode
there was a scene where Damon greinera
by her throat after she revealed the
secret her father had given her as you
all know that secret was what aegon saw
in his dream about the night king and
the White Walker threat that lies north
Beyond the Wall viserys gave her that
information when he made her his Heir
for the Iron Throne now during that
scene with Damon and runera they were
already arguing about when they should
go to war against Serato Allison and her
son aegon I think all of us could easily
see that Damon was already on the edge
but it was when rainera revealed that
secret that made him wrap his hand
around her throat ever since that
episode aired on Sunday hundreds and
thousands of fans have been wondering in
guessing why that happened there's
actually a lot of fans who are wondering
if Damon is on the verge of Madness
everyone wants to to know what actually
made Damon do this to not only his wife
but a member of his family well it looks
like we finally have the right answer
thanks to House of the dragon's writer
and showrunner Ryan Condell in a recent
interview he revealed exactly why that
happened and what was actually running
through Damon's mind in that moment he
said that is an incredibly shocking
scene and honestly one of my favorite
scenes of the finale that is wonderfully
done by Emma and Matt he also said
although it is a shocking scene Damon
has always been this way and the series
hasn't shied away from that I think
Damon has very much throughout this
season shown you a lot of different
sides of himself that would not lead one
to be all that shocked in that moment
that danger is always lurking beneath
the surface and it just happened to
reveal itself in that moment House of
the dragon's writer and shell Runner
also went on to say that learning
viserys didn't trust him with aegon's
dream is the final straw for Damon which
is why he snapped the way that he did it
was made very obvious to Damon meant
that his brother never really regarded
him as the heir of the Iron Throne that
Revelation infuriates Damon he said it's
the worst hurt that he could experience
to learn that viserys kept this secret
from him and that he so willingly shared
it with renero it just breaks Damon in
that moment and that's how he reacts so
as you can see House of the Dragon
showrunner basically said Damon was mad
because viserys gave that information to
raniera and not him it showed Damon that
viserys never actually considered him
for the Iron Throne now if you noticed
in that scene renera also has a very
interesting reaction during that
Revelation in the scene renera also
seems shocked to learn that viserys
never shared aegon's dream with Damon
I never told you
that's why she sort of half smiles when
she realizes her father did actually
only share that secret with her I think
it further demonstrates how serious
viserys was with making raniera his Heir
and in that moment Rainier understands
that as well this is something Damon
will have to eventually learn how to
accept let me know what all of you
thought about this scene down below I
still wish they would have left the
scene out of the episode but maybe some
of you feel another way as always I want
to thank all of you for watching another
one of my videos I hope all of you have
a great day I will see you again very
soon in the next one bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign